e eu queria conversar com você sobre
transumanismo
e se você não sabe o que é isso eu
sugiro que você fica tem eu vou me
esforçar nos próximos minutos para
tentar te convencer de que esse é um dos
temas mais importantes do século 21
e ele tem consequências tão grandiosas e
levanta questões de natureza ética tão
fundamentais que é fundamental EA
humanidade se proponha e se disponha a
discutir mas desde já
a subir o risco de ver a possibilidade
de ter transformada em distopia o futuro
supostamente O tópico que a ciência EA
tecnologia nos prometem
e vamos começar com origem do termo que
não pode ser considerado o recente se a
gente levar em consideração que na
Divina Comédia que é do século 14 Dante
Alighieri emprega o verbo transformar
uma variação de transumanismo para
descrever o processo da subida dele aos
céus na companhia de sua amada Beatriz
agora se essa é a citação conhecida mais
remota a citação moderna é atribuída a
Júlia foi um biólogo e Pensador
britânico irmão do escritor aldous
Huxley Admirável Mundo Novo e o 1957
Julian Huxley publicou um pequeno ensaio
ao qual ele deu exatamente o nome de
transumanismo e o que é então
transformar a muitos anos o ser humano
se acostumou a se valor a Se valer
é de fatores externos ao seu corpo com o
propósito de corrigir ou expandir
capacidades naturais de Eu por exemplo
uso óculos para corrigir minha visão e
se eu quiser ver uma coisa muito pequena
que mesmo uma visão perfeita não permita
eu me Vale de um microscópio
e agora o desenvolvimento muito
acelerado da Ciência e Tecnologia e as
perspectivas de que ele se acelere muito
mais abre portas para possibilidades que
até muito recentemente o homem nem
sequer sonhava nós estamos falando de
dotar o homem de capacidades que ele
nunca teve até essência da lógica do
trânsito nariz e eu vou tentar mostrar
isso para vocês com três exemplos
a primeira gente começa com uma história
que há quase erótica mas é rigorosamente
verdadeira e quem quiser pode acompanhar
lá na internet em 2015 executivos da
queira chique é uma rede de fast-food
que comercializa partes de frangos
Fritos eles processaram executivos de
chineses sobre acusação de que eles
estavam espalhando boatos de que os
frangos
e as partes de frangos vendidos pela que
ia ver se tinha um preços tão baixos que
elas só seriam economicamente viáveis xi
produzidas a partir de uma matéria-prima
vinda de frango geneticamente
modificados para terem seis asas e oito
pernas um essa imagem que vocês estão
vendo é obviamente uma montagem que tem
a opção de ilustrar a história engraçada
mas fiquem atentos porque a próxima
imagem não é uma montagem
e as imagens que vocês estão vendo agora
é ali ilustra uma linha de pesquisa que
tem o propósito de modificar
geneticamente animais para melhor
satisfazer os interesses e os apetites
humanos como se a imagem te deixou
chocado de alguma forma esse questões
éticas vieram a sua cabeça então talvez
seja importante que você saiba disso
Onde fica ações dessa natureza também
podem ser feitas em seres humanos e
talvez demore muito menos do que a gente
imagina E para isso acontecer vou tentar
mostrar porque ano passado em 2020 pela
primeira vez na história o prêmio Nobel
de química foi concedido as duas
mulheres uma francesa que trabalha na
Alemanha e uma americana que trabalha na
no post of Califórnia em berkeley
bom e o que elas pesquisam é uma técnica
conhecida pelo nome em inglês crisper é
uma sigla que se refere ao estudo de
modificações genéticas em embriões para
a transformação de seres vivos inclusive
humanos vejam por exemplo que em 2017
duas das academias científicas de maior
prestígio no mundo inteiro que são as
ciências EA de medicina Americanas
publicaram um relatório conjunto em que
defendiam também pela primeira vez a
prática de Terapias genéticas com o
propósito de evitar que embriões humanos
se transformassem em seres humanos com
propensão a doenças potencialmente
fatais para as quais não há cura e
Tá bom quem acompanha o assunto como há
muito tempo como eu sabe que um
relatório desse dificilmente Vem do nada
não é uma coisa gratuita normalmente é
quer dizer é razoável supor pelo menos
que ele tenha sido financiado por gente
que tem o propósito de usar para
fomentar para abrir um debate público o
que eventualmente leva e a criação de
legislação que torne também legal o que
hoje é apenas científicamente possível
agora é claro se você consegue mudar um
embrião uma no para evitar que o ser
humano proveniente dele seja propenso a
uma doença eventualmente fatal você
também pode fazer o para torná-lo mais
inteligente maior mais forte enfim e
você quiser
e surgem questões óbvias né é o limite
diz quem vai usufruir diz quem puder
pagar nós vamos ter castas de seres
humanos geneticamente modificados de
acordo com o seu poder econômico
Oi e a pergunta do limite também é
adequada porque muita gente crê que as
viagens interplanetárias podem ser
precipitados pela perspectiva de colapso
ambiental agora como todo mundo sabe o
ser humano não foi criado pela revolução
darwiniana para participar de viagens
especiais ela pesado Ele come muito ele
enche é complicado levar um ser humano
para Marte por exemplo que é um lugar
relativamente perto em termos um
aniversário
é mas é os possível e tem gente
pesquisando isso modificado
geneticamente esse ser humano para
torná-lo menor massagem mais forte mais
resistente com menor necessidade
aeróbica mais longevo com pequeno
detalhe todavia esse novo cheiro pode
não mais ser um ser humano
é bom e mais você não transforma e
jornal alta no ET um injeção eram
necessários experimentos intermediários
e as questões que surgem elas ganham
Então até sinistro por exemplo e que a
gente faz com o resultado de
experimentos intermediários que digamos
assim não derem muito certo e também
isso me leva ao meu segundo exemplo se
eu comecei o primeiro com uma história
reddot que eu começo este com uma
pergunta
Oi hoje em dia quando a gente sabe que
alguém completou 100 anos a gente
festeja fica surpreso mas já não fica
perplexo porque há muito tempo isso
deixou de ser uma novidade bom você já
parou para pensar que você pode viver
muito mais do que isso E que seus filhos
e netos talvez possam viver duzentos ou
trezentos ou mais anos
O timão preocupar boa para pensar Talvez
seja hora de você fazer isso foi o que
fez por exemplo Bill Mary o festejado o
neurocientista que criou a Google frente
e foi seu primeiro cio há poucos anos de
Homero e criou a Kelly fornellas Company
aquele colégio e se vocês visitarem o
portal daquele coleps Vocês verão logo
na entrada e a missão dessa empresa é
enfrentar o envelhecimento um singenico
oxigeno propósito de curau
há alguns anos biomerge deu uma
entrevista dizendo que ele tinha quase
meio bilhão de dólares para investir
nessa iniciativa e nesta entrevista Ele
disse que ele acredita que pode viver
500 anos
Ah e não é maluco isolado pelo contrário
um festejado neurocientista que tem a
companhia por exemplo e Peter cio um dos
homens mais ricos do mundo Doutor por
Stanford que o criador do PayPal Só que
também deu uma entrevista há cerca de
dois anos depois de PMERJ em 2017 não me
lá em que ele diz que acredita que pode
viver para sempre que ele pode enganar a
morte eu não conheço cientistas sérios
falando em imortalidade porque não há
nenhum sinal que catástrofes doenças
acidentes possam todos ser evitados
é mas as pesquisas de enfrentamento ao
envelhecimento vão muito bem por exemplo
obra de Grey de Cambridge um pesquisador
britânico recentemente deu uma
entrevista em que ele avaliou em
cinquenta por cento a probabilidade de
que nos próximos 20 anos o homem vai
dominar não apenas o processo de
interrupção do envelhecimento Mas também
da sua reversão já estão falando nessa
possibilidade
Oi e para vocês verem como este é um
assunto importante recente na capa da
revista Nature e dezembro de 2020 pouco
tempo portanto aparece um artigo de um
professor de Harvard chamado David
Sinclair no qual ele fala sobre
resultados muito impressionantes na
reversão do envelhecimento de ratos
é bom questões você tá preparado para
viver num mundo em que as pessoas não
envelheçam mais ou que até se
rejuvenesce são você está preparado por
exemplo para ver seus pais eventualmente
fisicamente mais jovens do que vocês
depois de algum tipo de tratamento
é o que me leva o meu terceiro exemplo
este o comércio tentando quebrar aquela
ideia de que as coisas interessantes
estão sempre no futuro e nunca no
presente eu quero apresentar a vocês
rapidamente três dispositivos que estão
disponíveis para compra de internet é o
que a gente chama de dispositivos de
prateleira o primeiro deles é o deve que
dá next mãe que é um disco pequeno leve
e cerca de 60 gramas que você pode
prender na sua cabeça com auxílio de uma
banda elástica e o que ele faz é o
seguinte Ele captura as ondas elétricas
produzidas no seu cérebro através das
sinapses cerebrais ele decodifica ele
aprende um aprendizado de máquina um
significado daquelas ondas e executa a
intenção do usuário
e ele aprende e executa a intenção do
usuário dando a ele por exemplo controle
completo de um computador a conta dele
poder jogar videogame
e competindo como deve que que tem a
pulseira de resto da controle que faz
essencialmente a mesma coisa e foi
comprada pela Facebook há pouco mais de
um ano por 1 bilhão de dólares
o terceiro item que eu quero liso
mostrar é a coroa de ecrã da New Hit O
que é safaris é parecido como deve kit
mais além de capturar as ondas elétricas
do cérebro ela interage com essas ondas
elétricas buscando reformatação e
aumento da capacidade de concentração do
usuário
E que tal você imaginar você mesmo
competindo no exame de seleção com
alguém que faz uso de um recurso como
esse será que isso ajuda alguém entender
o absurdo que é questionar políticas
públicas de ações afirmativas a partir
de argumentos como a meritocracia
tá dando um salto agora vamos falar de
algo que é futuro mas é um futuro
aparentemente próximo e diz respeito a
empresa neuralmente criada por Lilo
romance que a querida a tese da spacex e
esse é um procedimento invasivo ao
contrário dos outros porque ele prevê a
inserção de um pequeno disco do tamanho
aproximado de uma moeda no topo da
cabeça de uma pessoa e se discutem chips
e tem uns fios muito finos que tem o
propósito de se conectar fisicamente com
a rede neural do cérebro já tem até uma
máquina um protótipo de uma máquina que
faz a cirurgia completa de implante
e vamos propósitos declarados imediatos
são por exemplo o da cura da
tetraplegias algo muito Nobre mas os
propósitos futuros são quase aqui
limitados eles vão dar a telepatia algo
Óbvio por um
um por um dispositivo dessa natureza até
por exemplo a conexão da mente humana
com a chamada Nuvem de informações de
muita gente crê e romântico é um deles
que é única forma do ser humano
conseguir manter o contrato e talvez
controle daquilo que muita gente
considera a assustadora Perspectiva da
Inteligência Artificial forte ou geral
e não há conhecimento de experimentos
feitos com seres humanos mas já com
animais como porcos e macacos e quem
quiser pode encontrar grande material a
respeito na internet
E com isso concluo mais antes eu queria
fazer uma reflexão rápida e começa com
uma história muito conhecida Santos
Dumont inventou o avião e anos mais
tarde se suicidou até uns saiba pelo
menos também pela depressão causada por
ver a sua invenção transformada em arma
e Destruição e morte eu considero este
um exemplo lapidar do conflito do
paradoxo que pode haver entre uma Utopia
no sonho idealizado e uma distopia
concretizada em fatos
e isso é muito perigoso porque a
história humana é muito ruim a história
do sofrimento da dor causada tanto pela
natureza pela pela forma pela doenças
epidêmicas tanto por causas nada
naturais como a violência impingida
pelos mais fortes aos mais fracos
e quem tratou disso muito bem
recentemente foi um líder indígena e
filósofo chamado Ailton krenak escreveu
um livro chamado ideias para adiar o fim
do mundo no qual ele trata ele
desenvolve a tese de que a humanidade
nem sequer existe Porque se ela
resistisse ela seria tão má que aí eu
tenho treinados faz questão de dizer e
não se sente parte dela e eu acho que é
o caso da gente refletir a respeito
mesmo a volta dizer a história da
humanidade não é boa a história de
injustiças colossais por exemplo a
escravidão
é algo tão gigantesco que não há como se
falar em correção e reparação é
impossível
E agora se
E é difícil a gente falar sobre o
passado e como corrigir Lu há muito que
a gente possa fazer pelo presente e pelo
futuro e é por isso que eu acho tão
fundamental e as questões como essas que
eu procurei ilustrar nessa conversa
sejam discutidas e sejam discutidas
imediatamente vejam por exemplo eu
apresentei a vocês eu me referia a cerca
de dez pouco mais de 10 pessoas nessa
apresentação todas elas com exceção do
canal eram brancas e de origem
caucasiana e
e eu fui professor de estatística minha
vida inteira eu me considero habilitado
para levantar No mínimo a suspeita de
que o sonho utópico dessa fração da
espécie humana não necessariamente
representa o sonho utópico de todo o
resto da espécie humana e não faz parte
dela
e a humanidade chegou até aqui sem
compreender que ela tem muito a ganhar
se conseguir construir o mundo em que
valores como a solidariedade a inclusão
a cooperação o respeito à diferença
prevaleçam sobre os valores da ambição
predatória e até aqui tem regido a a
humanidade
e até aqui o ser humano não foi capaz de
entender isso
não me agrada pensar ou ao menos desejar
eu transumanismo nos leve a um grau de
consciência e nos permita alcançar essa
Conquista
é muito obrigado